once leader of myanmar now prisoner of
its military government and leaders of
the junta
aung san tsuchi together with ousted
president win mint found guilty of
incitement and breaking coronavirus
rules they denied all charges which many
believe are trumped up
the junta says suchi has been given due
legal process
it's the first verdict of 11 charges
suchi faces including corruption and
electoral fraud
online definitely wants to lock her up
because the military junta is extremely
afraid of the popularity she commands
but i think um the the jailing aung
sangsuchi for the rest of her life is
not going to stop the resistance
we're seeing a huge resistance from
young people
who refuse to um to stop fighting
against this illegal military junta
condemnation of the verdict has been
swift a spokesman for a group
coordinating opposition to the junta
says the military rulers have betrayed
the people of myanmar
so it is the distractions of
our hopes and our dreams and our vision
for the democratic union of myanmar
so this is nothing to do with us as a
rule of law the u.n human rights chief
michelle bachelet has criticized the
conviction as politically motivated
describing it as an attempt to remove
all opposition
tsuchi faces verdicts on another case
against her as early as next week
she could be sentenced to more than a
hundred years in prison if found guilty
of all charges
florence louis al jazeera